[Aplausos]
[Música]
tal y como os contamos el día 30 de
junio del 2020 todo cambio en hong kong
ese día un martes que pasa en la
historia como una jornada triste para la
democracia el partido comunista de china
de una vez por todas dio por finiquitado
el modelo la política de un país dos
sistemas no lo hizo como algunos
esperaban mediante una impactante
ocupación de tropas ni nada por el
estilo sino mediante una gris votación
en el comité permanente de la asamblea
nacional popular lo que viene a ser el
parlamento de china en esa votación
ratificó la entrada en vigor de una
nueva ley de seguridad en la ex colonia
británica queridos amigos hablamos de
una nueva ley que en la práctica y entre
otras cosas ha puesto punto y final a la
libertad de expresión manifestación o
asociación política algo que durante
décadas convirtió hong kong en uno de
los territorios más libres de todo el
planeta de esta forma desde el día 1 de
julio cualquier plataforma social medio
de comunicación empresa editorial o
centro educativo está en el punto de
mira de la dictadura china para que os
hagáis una idea con esta ley que será
aplicada por tribunales y fuerzas de
seguridad especiales y controladas
por pekín cualquier acción que el
régimen chino considere que promueve la
sedición la subversión el separatismo o
la colusión con fuerzas extranjeras
puede terminar en duras penas de cárcel
e incluso en la cadena perpetua
[Música]
amigos la ley de seguridad es un cheque
en blanco para que el gobierno chino
pueda perseguir en hong kong a cualquier
persona movimiento que le sea incómodo y
por supuesto tal y como os podéis
imaginar su uso no se ha hecho esperar
represión y miedo son dos términos que
ahora se han convertido en parte de la
vida cotidiana en este enclave en el mar
del sur de china
la nueva política tanto de pekín como de
las autoridades locales es combatir
duramente cualquier muestra de
disidencia o momento no me creéis
pensáis que estoy exagerando pues
atentos al tipo de titulares que ahora
se han convertido en algo cotidiano de
la actualidad
hong kong es a los activistas joshua
guangya cnet show de hong kong
encarcelados por su rol en las protestas
los activistas prodemocracia se
enfrentan a meses entre rejas con más
cargos pendientes 7 legisladores
prodemocráticos arrestados en hong kong
solías ver libros críticos con las
autoridades en hong kong ahora esas
obras ya no se ven en las librerías jury
suzuki socio senior del bufete de
abogados asumían zach la última vez que
vi a muchos de mis amigos de las redes
sociales en línea fue el 30 de junio el
día en que villena aprobó una ley de
seguridad nacional para hong kong mi
lista de amigos a corto y algunos
reaparecieron con nombres
reconocí muchos eliminaron sus cuentas
por temor a que pudieran ser perseguidos
incluso por el menor desaire contra el
gobierno nicole el you reportera del
financial times en hong kong amigos del
inicio de las protestas masivas en 2019
casi 10.000 personas han sido arrestadas
y miles de ellas procesadas sin embargo
desde que la nueva ley de seguridad
nacional entró en vigor las cosas se han
puesto mucho pero que mucho peor fijaos
[Música]
desde que la nueva ley entrará en vigor
docenas de figuras claves en favor de la
democracia han sido detenidas incluidos
varios legisladores en agosto la policía
hizo una redada en el apple daily uno de
los pocos medios de comunicación no
controlados por 'the king' y mila y el
fundador del periódico junto con otras
ocho personas incluidas dos hijos suyos
fueron arrestados bajo la nueva ley de
seguridad y el pasado 2 de diciembre las
autoridades le negaron a jimmy lai
incluso a la libertad provisional el 3
de septiembre 12 activistas
prodemocracia fueron capturados por la
guardia costera de china mientras
intentaban una dramática fuga en una
lancha de wang el más joven tenía 16
años
[Música]
y amigos estos son tan sólo tres
ejemplos de lo que supone la nueva
normalidad para los hongkoneses sin
embargo esperar su momento porque aquí
no termina todo
[Música]
el pasado 12 de noviembre las
autoridades chinas dieron una nueva
vuelta de tuerca todo este asunto
autorizaron al gobierno de hong kong
expulsar permanentemente a cualquier
legislador esto es a cualquier diputado
que no sea considerado lo
suficientemente patriótico y ojo que
esto es lo más llamativo esta expulsión
no tiene que pasar por los tribunales
locales es decir para entendernos ahora
la autoridad ejecutiva de hong kong que
es elegida por el gobierno chino y que
actualmente lidera la señora carry la
puede con toda impunidad y sin respaldo
judicial alguno expulsar a los diputados
que le sean incómodos del parlamento de
hong kong así que minutos después de que
entrará en vigor esta nueva norma cuatro
miembros de la oposición fueron
expulsados del parlamento es decir en
otras palabras en el parlamento de hong
kong ya no hay sitio para la oposición
el gobierno ahora puede eliminar a
cualquier cara que no le gusta del
parlamento no habrá futuro para esta
legislatura que nestlé un uno de los
diputados expulsados para colmo en su
último discurso político anual la jefe
ejecutivo de hong kong carril am
calificó a la ley de seguridad como
notablemente eficaz y se comprometió a
promover la educación patriótica lo que
ya os podéis imaginar que significa pero
todo esto amigos es algo de lo que en
cierta forma ya os hemos hablado y
además estoy seguro seguro de que casi
ninguno de vosotros os resultará extraño
ahora bien la cuestión es qué
consecuencias puede tener esta
injerencia política cuáles son las
fortalezas de esta región cada vez menos
autónoma y la pregunta más importante de
todas que espera o que necesita china de
hong kong atentos
[Música]
wall street' de gracia amigos la antigua
colonia británica se convirtió durante
el siglo 20 en un importante enclave no
sólo comercial sino sobre todo
financiero es un sistema legal inspirado
en el modelo británico y que daba mucha
seguridad jurídica una enorme libertad
de movimiento de personas capitales y
mercancías bajos impuestos y el inglés
como idioma de referencia fueron sólo
algunos de los elementos que lo
catapultaron a lo más alto de los
rankings financieros internacionales
pero eso eso no es todo el espectacular
despegue de la economía china durante
las últimas décadas lo veréis él porque
ha convertido a hong kong en el centro
financiero internacional más importante
del mundo tan sólo por detrás de nueva
york y londres sin ir más lejos en 2019
la bolsa de hong kong fue la que más
dinero recaudó con nuevas salidas al
mercado se situó por encima del nasdaq
de la mismísima bolsa de nueva york
y en 2020 la cosa no es muy distinta la
bolsa de hong kong y el nasdaq compiten
mano a mano por esta simbólica primera
posición
[Música]
hong kong ha sido parte de china desde
1997 sin embargo como todos sabéis su
estatus internacional ha sido la
práctica como el de un país
independiente por ejemplo la ley de
política de hong kong de los eeuu de
1992 hizo que durante todos estos años
en este territorio fuera considerado
como una zona aduanera distinta china y
estuviera garantizada la convertibilidad
monetaria y no es la única regulación
que existe porque son muchos los
acuerdos que han dado forma hong kong
esta forma sin ir más lejos la sé que el
supervisor de valores de wall street-
tiene un acuerdo de aplicación con su
amor o hong kong es muchas normativas
son similares y sus empresas de
derivados financieros son tratados por
los organismos norteamericanos como si
fueran empresas prácticamente locales lo
cierto es que la mayoría de supervisores
bancarios y financieros de todo el mundo
tratan a las entidades con con esas como
si estuvieran radicadas en el mismísimo
frankfurt todo esto ha conformado un
ecosistema único y tremendamente
competitivo
aunque de todas tal vez la
característica más importante es la de
ser el centro de financiación en dólares
más destacado de todo el continente
asiático desde 1983 su moneda el dólar
de hong kong ha estado vinculado al
billete del 'tío sam' un vínculo
respaldado por reservas de más de 400
mil millones de dólares es decir para
entendernos si quieres o necesitas
dólares en ansiedad hong kong es tu
sitio
ah
pues bien son todas estas
características que os hemos comentado
lo que explican este pequeño enclave ese
un lugar tan bullicioso especialmente si
hablamos de dinero con poco más de siete
millones y medio de habitantes en hong
kong estaban establecidos 163 bancos
distintos la mayoría de ellos
internacionales por supuesto
prácticamente todas las grandes
entidades del mundo tienen operaciones
en este lugar para que os hagáis una
idea el 13% de todo el empleo y el 26
por ciento de su economía proceden de la
industria financiera ahora bien dicho
esto hay una pregunta esencial que
tenemos que contestar qué papel juega
hong kong para china como de importante
es esta ciudad para la economía del
gigante asiático y ojo porque estas dos
preguntas tienen implicaciones quizás
mucho más importantes de lo que te
puedas imaginar atentos
cuanto necesita china hong kong
amigos aparentemente podríamos decir que
la importancia que tiene hong kong en la
economía china se ha reducido mucho
durante las últimas tres décadas al fin
y al cabo si en 1993 hong kong
representaba el 27 por ciento de todo el
pvd china hoy esa cifra es de menos del
3% de hecho sin ir más lejos en 2019 el
pib de la provincia de shenzhen superó
al de hong kong
sin embargo esperar un momento porque el
peso la influencia la importancia de
esta región administrativa especial se
manifiesta de forma muy diferente porque
a pesar de que hong kong cada vez es más
y más chino hasta ahora sus
instituciones han sido prácticamente
equivalentes a las de una economía
occidental me estoy refiriendo por
ejemplo a los tribunales los reguladores
o la autoridad monetaria instituciones
todas ellas que han funcionado desde
hace décadas de una forma independiente
y eficaz y no sólo son las instituciones
esta ciudad también está repleta tal y
como ocurre en el caso de la city de
londres de todo tipo de profesionales
ligados al mundo financiero muy
especializados desde despachos de
abogados hasta gestores de patrimonio
analistas o tecnologías fintech gracias
precisamente a yo con con se ha
convertido en algo así como una especie
de interconector entre dos mundos muy
distintos por un lado el mundo
occidental y por otro el próspero mundo
nuevo de la china moderna
y
[Música]
mientras que el sistema financiero
occidental se caracteriza por la
libertad de flujos de capital la
difusión libre de información y la
seguridad jurídica en china las cosas
son aún bastante diferentes los
controles son los movimientos de
capitales siguen siendo enormes al
tiempo que bueno digamos que la
seguridad jurídica no es el elemento más
característico de china
vamos como de ninguna otra dictadura el
caso es que precisamente por estas
diferencias con con juega un doble papel
por un lado es la principal puerta a la
china continental de la inversión
extranjera y por otro es el lugar donde
las empresas chinas incluidas ojo las
grandes empresas públicas recaudan
fondos especialmente claro está- dólares
del 'tío sam' pensar que para hacer
operaciones internacionales puedes
contar con los billetes del imperio
americano es agua casi imprescindible
pues de esta forma si buscáis conseguir
joanes para invertir en china y queréis
poder cambiarlos con cierta libertad
interior garantías y seguridad jurídica
amigos hong kong es exactamente la
puerta a la que tenéis que llamar porque
amigos esta ciudad no sólo es el centro
de financiación en dólares más
importantes de asia también es el mayor
mercado de joanes fuera de la china
continental de todo el mundo
central el distrito financiero de hong
kong es por ejemplo el lugar donde los
emprendedores y líderes tecnológicos de
china hacen acuerdos con los hedge funds
norteamericanos para captar financiación
al tiempo que en el mismo lugar los
grandes bancos públicos de china emiten
bonos para financiar proyectos como la
nueva ruta de la seda también es el
lugar donde cotizan decenas y decenas de
empresas chinas entre ellas 4
una empresas controladas por el propio
gobierno chino al fin y al cabo cotizar
en hong kong supone abrir la puerta a
los inversores y al capital de todo el
mundo para que os hagáis una idea de los
casi 75 mil millones de dólares que las
empresas chinas captaron en las bolsas
durante el 2019 cerca de la mitad
provino de esta ciudad esto es lo que
explica que más del 70% de la
capitalización total en la bolsa de hong
kong corresponde a empresas chinas y
mientras los chinos utilizan este
mercado para poner a buen recaudo muchos
ahorros y las empresas chinas lo usan
para captar dinero inversiones y socios
así como para financiar sus proyectos en
el exterior los inversores
internacionales producen también como
puertas de entrada al gigante chino
según datos de morgan stanley en 2018
por ejemplo más del 60 por ciento de la
inversión extranjera directa en el
gigante asiático se canalizó desde aquí
desde esta ciudad desde central desde el
distrito financiero de hong kong más del
60 por ciento así que ya lo veis es de
cierta forma hong kong sigue siendo
indispensable para china digamos que
erosionar la pujanza financiera podría
conllevar muchos pero que muchos
problemas para 'the kills' sin embargo
un momento en cierto modo eso es lo que
puede ocurrir con todo lo que os hemos
contado al principio del vídeo
y atentos
[Música]
ciudad global fuerte chino amigos podría
un analista de hong kong poner en
cuestión no sea una gran empresa pública
bajo las nuevas normas podrían los
inversores confiar en los tribunales si
se enfrentan a alguien cercano al
partido comunista chino puede una
información económica o un análisis
crítico con el gobierno ser perseguido
podría china dificultar el acceso libre
a la red en hong kong llegado el caso se
sentirán los profesionales de alto nivel
cómodos asumiendo una menor libertad de
expresión cómo se comportaban los
ahorros ante una merma en la seguridad
jurídica ojo amigos que no son preguntas
menores este es el nuevo escenario al
que se enfrenta hong kong y
particularmente su célebre centro
financiero
[Música]
por ejemplo según algunas encuestas
publicadas tras anunciarse la ley de
seguridad muchas empresas la mayoría
querían que esta nueva ley les afectaría
negativamente una encuesta realizada a
principios de agosto por la cámara de
comercio americana en hong kong te
encontró que el 75 por ciento de los
encuestados se sentía pesimista sobre
las perspectivas de negocio en esta
ciudad y que casi el 40% planeaba mover
su capital operaciones o activos a otro
lugar
fijaos lo ocurrido por ejemplo con and
financial el día 5 de noviembre 2020
esta empresa que es algo así como la
final financiera real y va y va a
comenzar a cotizar en la bolsa de hong
kong se trataba de la mayor salida a
bolsa de toda la historia en todo el
planeta sin embargo unos días antes a
finales de octubre su fundador jackman
se mostró crítico con el gobierno chino
en un foro financiero de shanghai pues
bien sabéis lo que ocurrió que de la
noche a la mañana el gobierno chino
suspendió la salida a bolsa de este
gigante valorado en cientos y cientos de
miles de millones de dólares
estadounidenses según se especulaba fue
el propio sigue en pin quien tomó la
decisión y claro no parece la mejor
forma de ganarse la confianza de los
inversores o de demostrar que las cosas
en el nuevo hong kong van a marchar bien
no os parece
amigos el futuro de hong kong
particularmente desde su posición como
centro financiero internacional pues no
está nada clara todo apunta a que poco a
poco cada vez será más chino y menos
internacional no sé cuál va a ser el
futuro de hong kong pero estoy bastante
segura de que no será un centro
financiero global hong kong es ahora el
centro financiero de china que es algo
diferente alicia garcía-herrero
economista jefe para asia pacifico de
natixis pero evidentemente incluso de
ser éste el escenario seguiría siendo
malo para china reduciría su conexión
financiera con el resto del mundo podría
reducir el número de inversiones
captadas el acceso a dólares o
incrementar el coste de capital para sus
empresas ese es el gran riesgo que se
enfrenta ahora al gobierno chino aunque
públicamente manifiesta en una idea algo
diferente lo que china hong kong y la
comunidad internacional más necesitan de
hong kong es estabilidad y un retorno al
orden si se puede mantener la ley y el
orden habrá un gran interés en todo el
mundo por seguir invirtiendo en esta
región mientras los inversores buscan un
crecimiento rápido y rendimientos
rápidos one julia o asesor del gobierno
central chino y presidente del centro
para china y la globalización amigos ya
lo veis en pekín consideran que
manteniendo las cosas calmadas con con
no se resentirá o al menos pues no lo
hará mucho lo que puede ser
en cualquier caso así están las cosas y
la pregunta que podemos hacernos es
tiene en mente algún plan b pues si por
ejemplo uno que tiene mucho pero que
mucho que ver con marcado pero de eso
les hablaremos en un próximo vídeo aquí
en visual político así que ya sabes no
te olvides suscribirte al canal si aún
no lo has hecho y darle al botón de like
bien fuerte si este vídeo os ha
resultado interesante una vez más muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]